so
[Music]
alas the sequel to breath of the wild
was once again a no-show at this year's
game awards but we did actually get some
new info on the game though not through
conventional means like a trailer teaser
or update from the man himself agl numa
but instead a series of patents issued
by the nintendo corporation regarding
some of the new mechanics in the game
now some might be under the impression
that these patents are brand new but the
actual application was done a while ago
they were made public on december 2
2021. however if you look at the date of
demand they were issued between may 24
and 26 which is about three weeks before
the second teaser was dropped at e3 the
mechanics featured in these patents
include time reversal passing or phasing
through ceiling objects and link's new
maneuverability while airborne each one
of these mechanics was shown or at least
hinted at in the 2021 teaser which i'm
sure is the reason why nintendo applied
for the patents right before the e3
presentation now of course patents in
video games are nothing new in fact as
of 2020 nintendo themselves have the
highest number of active patents out of
all major gaming companies and we're not
just talking about logos names and
characters either but gameplay mechanics
and hardware design too for instance
nintendo has long held a patent on the
look of the d-pad which expired in 2005.
up until 2012 corkscrew loops like the
ones from sonic the hedgehog 2 were
patented by sega which is why you didn't
see them in other games at the time or
bandai namco's claim on the training
mode from tekken which has always been
superior to contemporary fighting games
especially when it came to practicing
timing and inputs and there are many
more examples where a specific type of
game or hardware design is protected
although sometimes considered
controversial and in a few instances
subject to petty abuse in most cases
patents are a necessary business tactic
to protect certain ideas especially
during the development stage imagine if
another developer spots your idea in one
of your trailers then creates a game
with that exact same mechanic and
releases it before you do that would be
pretty bad however unlike other
registered ip writes like a copyright
for instance which only cost about to 65
bucks the application for a patent can
be quite costly ranging from 10 000 to
20 000 each it's mostly reserved for big
and wealthy corporations as opposed to
small indie developers patents are also
subject to rigorous examination before
being approved if an idea is too broad
or something similar already exists
chances are it's gonna get rejected
which is why i'm quite curious what
these patents for breath to wall 2 will
mean for the gameplay as some of these
don't exactly seem like the most novel
concepts out there rewinding time that's
been done many times before passing
through a wall or in this case a ceiling
a bit more obscure i guess but i'm sure
there's games out there that have done
something like it same goes for
controlling your character pose
orientation and camera position while
skydiving i've taken the effort to read
through every text inside the patents
devoted to the actual mechanics
themselves and translate it to more
simple terms as the raw descriptions are
overly technical convoluted and
incredibly repetitive trust me it wasn't
exactly an exciting read and by god do
they love using the words non-limiting
for some reason today we'll only be
focusing on the time reversal mechanic
see how it works the implications
restrictions possibilities etc if i find
anything interesting about the other two
mechanics i'll be making a separate
video for those two i will also be
sketching some very simple gameplay
examples just for the fun of it though
do keep in mind that these probably
won't represent the actual final product
even with all this info we won't know
exactly how it works until we finally
see it in action with that said let's
get started
as stated before i will only be focusing
on the actual description of the
mechanic paired with the illustrations
which are elaborated on in the
description as well there's a lot of
other information but most of it isn't
interesting to us it's your typical
legal stuff like document numbers dates
of issue and publication the cooperative
patent classification basically the
category and subcategories the patent
falls under depositors legal claims
receipts attorney-related stuff and so
on the mechanic in question is described
as a return movement and was requested
on may 24 2021 the people credited as
inventors include programmer naoki
fukada game designer corey bonnell one
of only a few westerners actively
working as a member of the zelda death
team in japan and who also worked on
breath the wild prior and game level
designer yuya sato like i said before
time manipulation and in particular
rewinding is nothing new there's a vast
list of games that feature a mechanic to
rewind time in some way shape or form a
famous example being prince of persia at
the sands of time which gives you the
option to reverse the flow of time for a
maximum of 10 seconds into the past and
get a do-over in case you make a mistake
blinks the time sweeper on the original
xbox had the option to freeze slow down
or rewind time and in a more recent
example game of the year winner it takes
two we also find a way to reverse time
in specific scenarios and there's much
more where that came from so what makes
breath the wall 2's rewind mechanic
different the introduction states that
movement related parameters used in a
virtual physical calculation are changed
such that the designated object selected
based on an operation input is caused to
perform a return movement to return to
previously recorded positions and
orientations in more simple terms it
means that with a specific input the
player can rewind time on selected
physics objects and return it to a
previous position in time the same way
stasis could freeze one object at a time
in breath the wild now in the games i
mentioned earlier when you reverse the
flow of time either everything plays in
reverse including the player or
everything but the player does but in
breath to wall 2 we can clearly see from
the trailer that even though the entire
screen turns black and white the spike
ball is the only thing moving back in
time the enemies and presumably link
himself continue to move as normal even
this on its own isn't really all that
groundbreaking you can easily find
tutorials online on how to do this kind
of stuff in unity or the unreal engine
rewinding objects to a previous state
while the player character remains
unaffected it doesn't even require all
that much coding either however i did
find one interesting thing about breath
while 2's rewind mechanic that makes it
stand out and might be the reason why
nintendo patented the code but before i
get into that i first need to explain
how rewinding time on objects is
generally achieved in video games
whenever the player interacts with a
physics object the game executes a
series of calculations to determine how
that object should behave and where it
should end up in most cases these
calculations are based on real-life
classical physics factors like the mass
of the object friction gravity velocity
angular velocity the force enacted upon
the object things like that so in order
to place something in reverse you'll
need to somehow keep a record of where
that object started in the virtual space
its previous trajectory how long it took
to get there its orientation and other
factors like acceleration and
deceleration in a video game there's
only three types of data needed for this
the position data orientation or
rotation and the time scale which in
video games is determined by frames one
way to do it is to record the object's
position and rotation data for each
individual frame inside of a buffer once
you have that data stored you then
essentially reverse the array and play
the animation in reverse frame by frame
again when executing the rewind mechanic
another way would be to only record data
for specific frames say every 10 frames
and then interpolate between them as you
play it back this is less heavy on the
memory since you don't have to store as
much data but the downside is that the
playback animation will be less accurate
since the system will have to estimate
what happened between those recorded
frames if you're interested in this kind
of stuff there's a great talk at the gdc
by the creator of braid a great indie
game that also uses an elaborate rewind
mechanic according to the description
breath the wall 2 will use the same
technique of recording object data frame
by frame and storing it in the dynamic
random access memory or dram for short
which corresponds with the first
technique of recording data frame by
frame however in a later section it also
states that it should be noted that the
time intervals at which the position and
orientation data are recorded may be
other time intervals eg one second
instead of a frame which is in line with
the second technique of interpolation i
guess maybe at the time of application
they hadn't made a definitive choice on
which technique they will ultimately use
or maybe they'll use both i have no idea
now in the case of prince of persia
everything on screen gets played back
basically the entire world state is
being buffered but in breath of the wild
too it'll only affect individual objects
physics objects such as crates barrels
and more which in the illustrations are
indicated by the name object m will be
selectable and then reversed given that
it has previously recorded position and
orientation data and it seems that this
data isn't just recorded when link
himself interacts with said object but
also when moved by an outside force as
we can see with the spike ball rolling
down the hill in the teaser which was
likely triggered by an enemy and not by
link yet he's still able to reverse it
it also hints that the reversal can be
cancelled at any moment by the player
quote the return movement of a
designated object may be allowed to end
halfway in response to the user's
operation of giving an instruction to
cancel the return movement additionally
in the illustrations we see some sort of
gauge indicated by the letter g which is
mentioned here quote in the case where
the remaining time indicator g is
displayed while a designated object is
performing return movement the processor
causes the remaining time indicator to
display the maximum remaining time at
the start of the return movement so yeah
as expected it's a time indicator that
shows how far back in time you can go
and will count down as the action is
performed how long we'll be able to
rewind and whether or not it's
upgradable is not mentioned though it
does mention an example time of 20
seconds the illustration also shows the
character running as the gauge is on
screen indicating that indeed we will
still have control over link while the
return movement is active but where
things get more interesting is the way
these objects will behave when traveling
backwards and might be where it stands
out from other games that use similar
mechanics the description states that
quote it should be noted that when a
designated object performing return
movement collides with another object or
character the state existence position
orientation or the like of at least one
of the colliding objects may be changed
as an example the state of at least one
object may be changed including
disappearance due to damage or the like
caused by the collision or the position
and orientation of at least one of the
objects may be affected depending on the
movement parameters at the time of
collision in other games when you rewind
time the object or entire game in some
instances is simply moving backwards
with the exception of the player choices
everything else will play out the exact
same way again after the rewind stops
while in reverse there won't be a sudden
collision of two objects where
previously there was none because all
objects are repeating what they did when
moving forward however in breath while
two according to the text and one of the
diagrams objects can actually receive
new collision data while moving
backwards so say for example you hit or
throw a metal ball and it moves across
the environment then you place another
object in the path of its previous
trajectory since that object wasn't
there before the ball cannot travel back
in reverse the same way as its path has
been obstructed meaning it'll collide
with the other object on the way back
this will likely end the reverse motion
and a new trajectory will be calculated
based on the collision to demonstrate
the impact of this i'll use it takes two
as an example here we see a statue being
smashed which seems to use actual
shatter physics when you reverse time
it'll simply play that same animation in
reverse and that's it and when you
return the flow of time back to normal
the same thing will repeat every piece
will end up in the exact same position
once again regardless if a piece
interacts with the player model or any
other factor but with breath wall 2's
rewind mechanic even in reverse factors
like velocity angular velocity and the
mass of the objects are still taken into
account and used for new collision data
so even in reverse new scenarios are
allowed to take place and things won't
always simply repeat the exact same way
i have no idea how this works code wise
but well that's why i make youtube
videos and are not in japan working on
breathtak 2 right now like our man corey
over here the diagram also shows that it
takes into account the possibility of an
object disappearing which as the text
explains refers to unloading such as
when breakable objects are destroyed so
if instead of a metal ball it's a wooden
barrel the backwards collision will
break the barrel causing it to unload so
yeah it's pretty interesting to see what
kind of crazy stuff we'll be able to
pull off and it's likely that breathtak
2 will be a physics playground once
again just like its predecessor in terms
of limitations there's a couple of
mentions of what it cannot do one
instance describes that the motion of an
object can be reversed but other factors
like elemental effects cannot quote an
influence or the like exerted by the
movement of the movable objects on other
objects before the return movement
cannot be subsequently cancelled here
examples of transitional effects or
changeable states of the movable objects
include damage burning electricity
resistance leakage freezing and
disappearance depending on the material
of the object in the return movement
such transitionable states are not
caused to return to a previous state as
a quick example this means that if you
throw a barrel away and then set it on
fire it will reverse the motion of the
barrel but it continues to burn even
though technically it has surpassed the
point in time before you set fire to it
same goes for other effects like
freezing electric currents etc damage
done to the object will also not be
inverted or undone and destroying it
outright is also irreversible basically
the reversal mechanic only encompasses
the object's position and rotation
everything else will operate
independently from it as normal it
remains to be seen what other
limitations this mechanic will have for
example it doesn't say at which point
the recorded data for an object will be
removed or overwritten does it also
account for motion when carried can you
only rewind the object that was last
moved or does it keep records of
multiple objects at the same time and
you can rewind all of them and if so is
there a limit to that amount i'm
guessing it all depends on how many
types of objects can be rewinded and if
they'll be able to compress the data
somehow so far there's mentions of
circular cylinders cones truncated cones
discs rings barrels or hollow cylinders
but also objects with other shapes
breath of the wild had a lot of physics
objects not just balls barrels and boxes
but also weapons resources like
gemstones snowballs you name it i'd
imagine there has to be some sort of
limit to it as keeping track of the
frame data for hundreds of individual
physics objects would no doubt take up a
lot of memory the description also
elaborates on the visual design of the
mechanic but it's overly long way too
complex for what it tries to say and
basically boils down to it's pretty much
the exact same as in breath the wild you
select the object with the cursor it
lights up and you activate the ability
the only unique visual to the mechanic
is that the screen will apparently
become black and white that it displays
a yellow line which indicates its
previous trajectory and those
transparent clones of the object showing
where it was at certain times in the
past but we already saw that in the
teaser so lastly let's take a look at
some gameplay examples obviously there's
a lot of potential for combat like we
saw in the teaser so let's focus on
simple dungeon puzzles instead also in
these examples i will not take into
account other sheikah slate abilities if
we did these puzzles would be vain but
we don't know if they will make a return
in the sequel there's a room with a
switch and two gates one closed and one
open when the switch is held down it'll
trigger gate 1 to open however it also
lowers gate 2 preventing you from moving
to the next room inside the room is also
a box you take the box and place it on
the switch you then hit or throw the box
away from the switch causing gate 1 to
close and gate 2 to open again you then
stand between the two gates reverse time
on the box so it moves back onto the
switch and you can move on to the next
room or say you have a room with a
cannon that repeatedly shoots a ball
across the room there's a switch which
raises a pillar with another switch on
the side and back down again when you
step off the switch the goal is to make
the ball hit the second switch however
it's on the other side of the pillar so
the ball will never be able to hit it
and well as you probably guessed you
need to step on the switch just as the
ball passes it target the ball and
reverse it so it slams into the switch
and the door will open or an item will
appear or whatever again very simple
examples and i'm no level designer by
any means but given what we've seen from
the shrines in breath of the wild they
can make it extremely smart and complex
with multiple objects crazy physics
collisions you name it not to mention
that if the game has more interesting
abilities like the sheikah slave did
which it likely will you may need to use
the time reversal in conjunction with
other abilities or items like i don't
know a hook shot or something
additionally since we'll be able to
cancel the time reversal halfway as
described i can see even more
possibilities for complex puzzles and
that covers all the interesting stuff i
was able to find about the mechanic a
massive thanks to everyone who watches
my videos the people in my discord
community and of course my patreons and
channel members if you will please give
a warm welcome to random citizen and
mitch alvey for joining and to love list
hart and aaron for upgrading their
pledge as always you are amazing and i
cannot thank you enough and that
concludes the last video of the year i
want to thank each and every one of you
for making 2021 another amazing endeavor
enjoy the holidays have a great end of
the year celebration and i will see you
all in 2022. the year we might finally
see breath of the wild 2 become a
reality here's to that this is don
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you